the metropolitan police service
informally known as scotland yard is a
territorial police force responsible for
law enforcement
in the metropolitan police district in
london
under the metropolitan police act in
1829 the metropolitan police service was
founded
and on the 29th of september of that
year the first constables were put into
service
in 1837 the beau streak horse patrol
formed in 1805
was amalgamated into the mps along with
the marine police force
in 1839
as the police force for the capital the
mps has significant national
responsibilities
some of these include the coordinating
and leading of country-wide
counter-terrorism matters
protecting the royal family and certain
members of her majesty's government
the safeguarding of 164 foreign
embassies and high commissions
policing city and heathrow airport and
the protection of the palace of
westminster
the mps also deal with significantly
more protests and events than any other
force in the country
for example there were 3 500 such events
since 2016 alone
for this reason the mps has a number of
specialist units who are trained in more
specific roles
one of these units is the territorial
support group
the tsg was established in 1987
replacing the existing special patrol
group
they consist of highly trained officers
who specialize in public order
and large-scale riots their aim to
secure the capital against terrorism
respond to any disorder in london and
reduce priority crime
we're not in the action of responding to
such acts they patrol designated areas
that are experiencing serious levels of
gang violence
or disorder each carrier has an advanced
police driver
seven constables and a sergeant
territorial support groups are often
composed of three carriers
or 21 constables and three sergeants
reporting to an inspector
after the reactivation of team rainbow
in 2015
one mps officer was recruited to bring
his skills and expertise
to assist in the fight against terrorism
on a global scale
this officer was named clash
[Music]
[Applause]
this is where you stop
maroa evans codenamed clash is a
defending operator
in team rainbow clash has always been a
force to be reckoned with
towering above many of her peers at 5
foot 10 she naturally demands attention
from those around her
she grew up in the suburbs of london
england and was a fundamental part
in leading the fight against racist mobs
and individuals who threatened her
community
and her people a determined and
persistent person
she remained at the forefront of many of
the often violent altercations
until one day she ultimately lost her
mentor and closest friend
pearson in contrast to her methods
pearson had always been a peaceful
protester he was there day after day
protest after protest passively standing
up against the racist individuals
and the inhumane ideologies
he and claire shed many of the same
views on justice and inequality
they just chose to rally others in
different ways and while his non-violent
pathway
was not her idea of an effective measure
against the enemy
she valued the friendship and guidance
he had provided her throughout the years
on the day of his death he had been
attacked this peaceful man
while trying to do the right thing by
imploring some looters to stop raiding a
store
this backfired on him and led to him
being killed
clash was overcome with grief she
finally understood that while the path
he had chosen was not hers
her pathway needed to change
two months after his death clash offered
to assist the metropolitan police
service
in the hopes that she could make a
difference in return
they offered her a clean slate
her duty was in using her ability to
help stop protests from becoming a
deadly and out-of-control situation
eventually she began to realise that she
wanted to be a part of this organisation
entirely
so she joined the mps full-time as an
officer
early on in her career she often let her
temper get the better of her
and some officers saw this as an
opportunity to have it forcibly removed
from the organization
so they went out of their way to try and
provoke her
to them she was still the enemy who had
somehow managed to weasel away into the
mps
and could not be trusted she found
herself in a constant uphill battle
with every misstep and blunder being
highlighted and brought to her
superior's attention
yet she continued on she was there to do
a task
and to her it was much more than just a
job it was an opportunity to not just
dull the storm
but redirect it and heroes switching
sides didn't mean she wasn't still
protecting londoners from the racists
and agitators she was just executing it
from a different angle
and hopefully one that would have a
greater impact
as a street-hearted veteran she
certainly knew how to fight dirty
but the intention was so much more than
that and as one of the lead experts in
riot control
she brought in valuable knowledge to
scotland yard
eventually she graduated from hendon and
legitimately earned the respect of a
division and even the ones who had
initially opposed her
in 2011 class managed the front line of
the police territorial support group
and was an integral figure during the
london riots
it had begun during an initially
peaceful protest against the shooting by
the police
of a young man of mixed race
a number of rioters were motivated by
the anger and were against the brutal
treatment at the hands of the police
along with the grievances rising from
inequality and cuts to public services
the main responsibility during this riot
of the tsg and clash
was to stop the violence from spreading
to other districts and securing the
capital
while confronting the writers she had
once led and stood alongside
she was met with extreme hostility to
them
she was now the antagonist yet
undeterred
she held her ground alongside her fellow
tsg and proved once and for all to her
superiors that she really was a
commendable officer
in the line of duty as a result of her
exceptional bravery
and leadership during the london riots
clash obtained special permission to
attend the gold command meetings
here she was vital in the development
and devising of a number of new
anti-riot strategies
based on his skills as a riot leader in
the past
throughout her service she made 274
arrests became a detective constable
and eventually earned the queen's police
medal for outstanding vela
rainbow recruited clash as they founded
determination
insight and background along with their
service record
highly desirable impressive and driven
she brings the same tenacity to team
rainbow that got her recognized in the
metropolitan police
however she continues to remain a tough
nut to crack she keeps her cards close
to her chest
she has never really gotten over the
loss of pearson and no one really knows
including her what kind of life she
would have led without his mentoring
and or death what seems to hold true
is her determination to channel her
anger fight the good fight
and use his teachings to become a better
person
within team rainbow she has developed a
friendship with montana
a man of few words even among his
friends he believes there is a lot to
learn from other operators
including clash as he sees her immense
potential
he is naturally protective of her and
understands her hesitancy
and opening up to others especially
because of her troublesome past
and it's fair to say that clash respects
and admires montagna
along with his stern and commanding
mannerisms
he too has an imposing presence with his
unwavering gaze and six foot four frame
but also has a shared experience working
protection detail
at the g8 and g20 summits
and probably more importantly to clash
she sees him as someone she can compete
with
and who is a proven and worthy opponent
however and not really that surprising
clash does not see eye to eye with all
of the other operators
thatcher and her come from opposing
sides of the fence and from the military
and her from the police she has strong
left-leaning views of the world
such as freedom equality reform and
internationalism
while he aligned strongly with the
notions such as authority
hierarchy order duty and nationalism
both are very passionate people who
firmly believed in their organizations
and if these two managed to get into a
heated discussion and emotions were
running high
it could very easily become an extremely
volatile and intense situation
clash uses a crowd control electroshield
as your primary weapon
this bulletproof extendable shield is
able to slow down opponents by using a
high voltage charge field generator that
spreads out
directly in front of the shield hostiles
caught in the charge field generator
also sustain a small amount of damage
over time
[Music]
using the shield clash is effective at
blocking entry points
or slowing down a push from the opposing
force
clash's story shows the struggle she
faced on one side of the fence
yet with almost identical problems when
she joined up with what she would have
considered
the enemy when she was younger one of
those tough hardened woman that even i
as a six foot four man would be
concerned about bumping into on the
wrong day
once again i need to thank drenius a
long long-standing community
member on discord for helping me out
with the gameplay footage on yet another
siege video
he never asks for anything in return he
just does it for the love of games
in turn hoping for content like this to
only assist in building interest around
these titles
also he's a bloody nice guy to top it
off if you see him on discord give him a
virtual high five or
elbow bump or whatever you guys than
lockdown are allowed to do
thank you very much for watching and
i'll catch in the next one cheers
you